the growing threat of the omicron
variant just four days before christmas
we are in the middle of it is now the
dominant covet strain in this country
making up more than 73 percent of new
cases that's according to a cdc estimate
the very first omicron related death was
reported in texas yesterday the person
was not vaccinated president biden is
expected to address all of this in a
speech to the nation later today at
o'keefe is at the white house with more
in ed we understand that the president
just had his own very close call with
the virus good morning to you
that's right a staffer the president was
in close proximity to on friday tested
positive on monday the president was
tested he tested negative and he'll be
tested again on wednesday as for today
the white house says the president is
going to talk about the challenging
times we're facing but that the country
is better equipped to fight this next
wave of the pandemic
this is not a speech about locking the
country down press secretary jenn saki
says president biden will outline how
the country is prepared to fight omicron
and address the 40 million eligible
adults who are still unvaccinated he'll
issue a stark warning and make clear
unvaccinated individuals will continue
to drive hospitalizations and deaths in
his speech mr biden is expected to
emphasize cdc data that shows the
unvaccinated are eight times more likely
to be hospitalized and 14 times more
likely to die from covet the president
will also announce plans to send a
thousand military medical personnel to
help crowded hospitals and to deliver
free rapid tests straight to households
we have the tools now to really keep
ourselves safe in an interview with cbs
news's margaret brennan vice president
harris also pleaded with americans to
get their shots there is a lot about
this moment
that is frustrating but let's not forget
our individual power to actually do
something about it everyone has to get
vaccinated the vaccines are free they
are safe and they'll save your life is
it the fault of the unvaccinated i would
not blame it on anyone in that way
but it is more about individual
power and responsibility but it is clear
that everyone
has the ability to make a choice to save
their lives the message from the white
house comes as washington d.c declared a
state of emergency and issued a new
mandate i will reinstate a city-wide
mass order
we will be instituting dc a dc
government vaccine mandate
to include boosters and new york state
is battling record positive covet
infections for four consecutive days
this week it's very transmissible it
moves fast we have to move faster happy
new year final decision on whether to
hold the big apple's traditional new
year's eve times square ball drop is
expected later this week but in los
angeles omicron has already canceled the
party the celebration in grand park will
instead go virtual
as for the administration's expanding
testing plan new federal testing sites
will be opened across the country with
the first one coming to new york city
and americans will be able to apply
online for new at home tests
the administration says they're buying
500 million tests to distribute for free
all right some news there thank you ed
appreciate it